[Music]
hi my name is ganesh taylor
i'm a postdoctoral research fellow at
the francis crick institute which means
basically
i study embryonic development and
molecular biology so i'm a scientist
gosh thank you for joining us um i'm
going to talk a little bit about
genome editing today that's okay um
tell us a little bit about it and where
the sphere sits at the moment
sure so and genome editing is
the the newest name for a form of
technology that's existed for some time
namely its molecular systems that
researchers use to change dna
and the one that we've heard most about
at the moment is crispr cas9
that's the one synonymous with that term
and and it's kind of like
the iphone to the mobile phones right so
that technology's existed for a long
time
um but this one is far more powerful
than um any of the previous generations
and i think that's basically why this
sort of concern or why the debate about
it a lot at the moment
because um yeah with with increased
power
of a tool comes increased numbers of
things that we can
achieve or do and that can be used both
for
good and bad as it were and so people
are getting
concerned or at least starting the
debate and and that's an important thing
to be doing actually
well maybe we can go into those details
in the debate let's start with
what are some of the most important
potential benefits of genome medicine
so in my opinion and i'm a researcher so
i'm biased
but i think the most important use of
this technology actually is in the
research
field so um this this technology this
genome editing technology
represents um a tool that makes people
like me be able to
do better experiments to do cleaner
experiments in terms of
um cleanly deleting pieces of dna that
we're interested in
compared to other previous technologies
and that
literally translates into better results
things that are more reliable
more reliable data and so i think the
most um
the best application of this technology
is in the research field and that's
basically where we're going to find the
greatest gains
and in our lifetime perhaps what
everyday changes might just make
to normal people i mean
i i'm not a betting person i was going
to say i'm not a betting man
and so the honest answer is i don't know
um obviously we've already had cases of
patients with leukemia and such like
that have
been cured as far as we know using
slightly different generations of genome
editing technologies
so not crispr casting but of that sort
of ilk so
clearly at least in certain spheres of
medicine this might actually get some
further traction i think if i was to to
predict
another field that would probably adopt
this technology or would be
maybe wise to in my opinion i would be
agriculture and livestock
so that's one of the less contentious
fields where
you know the application is both easy
and effective and
you know the rewards are usually worth
the risk
and yet there's contention around gmf
do the potential benefits outweigh the
risks
and are is that contention perhaps
unfounded
so full disclosure i'm that's beyond my
scope of actual expertise my my sense
would be
that you know if you take a measured
scientific approach to these things you
don't tend to release these sorts of
organisms into the wild without having
done all the rigorous testing
necessary prior to that point so my
answer to you should be something along
the lines of i trust my scientific
colleagues to do their jobs
appropriately and not to
step outside the lines of what makes
scientific sense and
is reproducible and then on top of that
actually is deemed to be safe by the
unwanted by the public because of course
all research and all findings and all
innovation is held accountable by the
public and by the legislation and the
regulation that is created in light of
what the public want
so what should the public be wary of
with genome editing
i think they should be wary of um too
many partisan
opinions and um scam-mongering and also
yeah it's not a silver bullet they don't
exist so
just keep keep you cool be rational
about it
and try and let
let people do what they're meant to do
and is and
is the regulation in place to stop
partisan application of this gene
analytic
that's a that's a difficult question and
obviously there is a lot of regulation
already out there
actually um but um as we know from the
case earlier on this year
jian ku hai in uh in shenzhen in china
it was the first case of somebody who
did apply crispr
cas9 genome editing technologies in the
human
context and actually did implant embryos
that should never have been implanted
really
at least by western standards of
morality and ethics
into a into a woman and those babies
apparently were brought to term
so and and that that that occurred in a
in a state where there was actually
legislation or regulation and guidance
at least
um already in place so whilst it does
exist and of course
regulation is important and
people do sometimes break break the law
and break the rules don't they
let's talk about your um ethical
perspectives
is there a line an ethical line to be
drawn between
gene editing for medical purposes and
for enhancement purposes
so i think it's that's a sort of
somewhat semantic debate which is
fair enough absolutely and
it comes down to what do you define as
an enhancement
my personal opinion is as we are now in
this moment we are already enhanced from
what our biology deems us
or the fate that our biology would have
had for us right
so any intervention is an enhancement
in my book and so therefore there is no
line really
so there's no distinction then between
editing genes perhaps to remove
a disease that's passed down through
them
perhaps even a terminal disease and
editing genes to decide
the color of your children's hair or
their eyes
i mean so technically
if we're talking about the medical case
that you're presenting right we're
talking about single gene most likely
something
that we assume or know from years of
research it's going to give you
disease x y z whatever it is okay um
the application of this technology in
that context is a lot easier to do
actually because it's a single gene
the trait that you're describing on the
other hand like for example eye color or
hair color or you know the one that most
people often bring up is intelligence
things like that
they're polygenic right it means
multiple genes are involved
and so the possibility of doing that
mod modifying those traits is a lot
harder to achieve in a practical sense
okay so the honest answer to your
question
is there no difference between doing
this and doing that well technically not
really
but in terms of practically doing that
it's quite different
and on top of that the most important
thing to to to understand in this
context is we know one gene causes a
disease and therefore we remove it
the point about things like hair color
or eye color
is that they're often more sort of
they're about odds if you carry certain
variants you are more likely to be
of x or y phenotype you have blue eyes
you don't have blue eyes whatever it is
whereas on the other hand we're talking
about something where we have a
certainty or
relatively close to a certainty if you
have this gene
mutation you are going to have this
disease um
and basically i think my my personal
opinion comes down to the fact that i
think
you know we don't get a great deal of
choice about our genes before we're born
anyway
you don't get a choice if you're going
to have this mutation that's going to
give you an illness
or a choice about what your eye colour
is going to be because your parents
basically they reproduce and that's it
you get what you get given
so if my parents wanted to change that
for me by conscious choice i don't see
why that's any different
to them choosing where i'm going to grow
up or what school i'm going to go to or
how they're going to feed me or parent
me
but that's quite a contentious point of
view i realized because
them choosing what school you go to what
they feed you
those are situational factors linked to
socioeconomics their own circumstance
in the second start of them choosing
your hair color
um is they're not a are they not taking
away consent from yourself or in
something perhaps more serious than hair
color
and they're not taking away consent from
yourself even though at that point you
haven't yet been born
um i i hear your point um but again i
think my
my point stands i never consented to any
of the things that happened during that
point in my life
equally i don't consent to what school i
go to or how i get fed and arguably the
food and the nutrition that i'm exposed
to during my early years would have been
extremely important to my
future potential actually so i think
yeah i i don't i don't think so no yeah
will genome editing be a privilege for
the rich
i mean that's that's going to be
determined by us right
completely determined the technology
itself um
the actual molecular part of it is not
that expensive checking that the edits
that you wanted to
induce in a genome have occurred that
can't that is
relatively expensive but it's a lot
cheaper now than it ever was before so
sequencing entire genome is about what 1
000
dollars at this stage or something like
that so the cost is coming down so
that's quite expensive
when we talk about you know doing genome
editing in human beings
we we always we don't say explicitly but
we're talking about
contexts where basically if i was to
genetically modify my children i would
have to do that
in an ivf setting you can't just you
know this stuff or early embryonic
development happens usually inside a
human's body
so the cost of ivf is something that you
do need to factor into it and that's
actually an already existing social
construct right
where it is defined by money if you have
money you can afford it
so um
if it was to come into the market now it
probably would be because it has to be
put through an ivf sort of context and
that is as i just said already defined
by money
does it need to be that way no nothing
has to be that way but
that is how it is currently should
non-essential
i.e genome editing that does
that isn't to prevent as we said
something like um
uh degenerative disease should that be
subsidized by
a public health service absolutely not
no no
no no no it's not at all no so um just
to be very clear about this
i don't i'm not condoning that everybody
should get to pick the color of their
children's hair or
at least even attempt to try and do that
okay
because it would be an attempt as i said
these things are polygenic it's not
going to be a case of certainty
um but my point is just
people who have the means to choose what
type of education they give to their
children it's no different really to
sort of try and attempt to bring the
system so your children have whatever
traits you think it might be desirable
medical interventions on the other hand
are a slightly different ethical debate
because
if a child is born that has
carries certain genes that mean that
they're going to be heavily reliant on a
medical system
that is in this country for example
publicly funded that does become
a more public debate one might say or
cause of
um debate and do you have an answer to
that debate
um i'm going to go with a cop out line
on that front which is i have my
personal opinion but i can't speak for
everybody else and that's the point of
democracy and i
i strongly uh value a democratic
decision
and that's why debates and
places like this are really important
because it starts to inform people about
how this
technology works and starts getting
people to think about what they
make of this technology and what they
value and in the end presumably it would
always come down to
hopefully in the ideal democratic
scenario
some sort of public discourse that
shapes whether or not we do or don't
require people to use genome editing
under certain circumstances or allow it
to certain people if they should choose
to or absolutely prohibit it
you know so you work in science
communication as well
are there any myths that you would like
to break around genome editing or if not
that
since we're giving you a platform are
there any other myths that you
particularly like to break about the
areas that you work in
um thank you very much for that
opportunity um i guess i've kind of
already said it which is just
i find it really interesting that people
seem to think that um
that there's a silver bullet but there
isn't
and the most important thing that i
always find myself saying in these sorts
of contexts is
um yes in theory
this technology could make us all
smarter and more intelligent in theory
but it's a really important thing to
remember that we are only
able to achieve anything based on the
knowledge that we have and we do not
have the necessary and sufficient
knowledge
about these traits that we're so
interested in yet to be able to use this
technology to achieve it
namely in theory yes we could make
people more intelligent
but we do not know all the genes
involved or how they work or the
interplay of those genes
in actually creating superior or higher
intelligence for example
and so therefore right now absolutely
not we can't we cannot achieve that just
yet
so there's a big difference between in
principle and
yes absolutely tomorrow let's do it does
that make sense
yes what excites you most
right now about your areas of research
well yeah i i love my job i get i i
have to say that right now i love my job
um and actually mostly for for something
that we've already talked about
basically
i love the fact that i get to study
something that is so contentious
mostly because i don't think it should
be contentious but i think it's going to
be really
interesting to see how this plays out um
and i personally i see that as part of
claiming back
our respective identities i think it's
really important that
you know it's really important that we
study things like why
what what is it to be a female what are
the what are the biological
characteristics associated with
with having two x chromosomes or an x
and a y chromosome
and and how far does that extend and
what does that mean and
how does that impact what medicines we
take or or kind of things we should be
doing or shouldn't be doing
um and i think having more information
about that can only be a good thing
what is your experience as a woman and
stem theme
um i'm a really bad person to ask that
question too because i'm expected to toe
the party line and
i can't i can't do that i've
i'm a scientist it doesn't make a
difference if i'm a female or a male as
far as i'm concerned i've
never once been told i can't do
something or achieve something because
i'm a female
and perhaps i'm lucky to have never been
told something like that to my face or
perhaps i'm ignorant to have not ever
noticed it
i think life is hard enough as it is
without having to start developing
paranoias about whether or not i'm
being excluded from something because i
do or don't have the expertise or
whether it's simply because i'm a female
what i will say however is
i think greater than the issue of being
a female in stem
is a matter of money actually
um and it
takes a certain level of risk-taking to
be an academic um especially financially
speaking actually
they don't pay very much it's not a very
constant uh stable stream
of income or um career to take on board
and so on the whole it tends to be only
people who can afford to take those
kinds of financial risks that
feel comfortable or don't notice the
fact that that is the case
when it comes to academia and um so i
guess that's the biggest concern that
i've sort of had in my line of work and
you know you handle it
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you